hey guys it's mkbhd and today we're back
with a top five features in Ice Cream
Sandwich video so for those of you who
don't know ICS is what we're gonna call
it and it's the latest version of
Android 4.0 so we're gonna start with
number 5 and that's the brand new UI
overhaul the new layout of the home
screens and the brand new custom font
just for Android 4.0 Roboto overall I'm
a really big fan of this overhaul a
change the color scheme first of all to
be like a black and a cyan sort of a
blue color and the contrast looks really
good it's a high contrast sort of thing
very easy on the eyes the font is also
very easy on the eyes it gives a very
relaxed professional layout all the apps
that are native with Google stuff
including Google+ and Gmail and calendar
and everything have been laid out just
for Ice Cream Sandwich and they look
really good so everything looks really
professional and nice and laid out and
that's why I made number five number
four is the new browser now while it's
not Chrome for Android yet they're kind
of going in that direction right now as
you can sync your favorites and your
bookmarks from the browser on your
desktop to be on your Ice Cream Sandwich
device your tablet or your phone and you
can also have that tabbed browsing
experience you saw on tablets on your
phone so now the Galaxy Nexus can have
up to 16 tabs running you can swipe to
exit those tabs and you can swipe
through to view the different tabs pull
them up close them all sorts of
different things so we've been looking
forward to that since it arrived on the
galaxy s2 so now it's built into stock
Android and the stock browser is looking
pretty good so I'm definitely looking
forward to that
number 3 is face unlock now I could just
stop right here just go like this but
I'm actually gonna explain it to you
basically you can go through the
security settings and open up the unlock
features and go ahead and let it scan
your face for a second and then put in a
backup code unless you just lose your
face or something but then you can lock
your phone and when you unlock it it'll
use the webcam on the front the 2
megapixel camera to just look at your
face and unlock it with your face it's
kind of nice I know having the camera
unlock directly from the lockscreen and
I don't think you get that with the face
unlock but hey I'm looking forward to
that just because of the possibility of
the new API what developers can do with
that front facing camera ideas
ideas number two the number two feature
is Android Beam if you guys forgot about
that it's one you can take to Ice Cream
Sandwich devices with near-field
communication or NFC chips in them and
touch them together and what whatever
app you're running on one phone you can
touch to beam to the other phone
now you're touching the backs together
so you can beam one and look at the
other and it will show up you can beam
all kinds of things like map locations
or applications or you know YouTube
video links say you're watching a video
you want the other person to watch if
you're if you're using an application
that you want the other person to use
say they don't want to look through the
market just go ahead and tap to beam it
and the other phone will have a link to
the Android Market with that app so
Android Beam is pretty sick I'm gonna be
using it with some of my android 4.0
buddies down the hall so yeah I'm
definitely looking forward to that and
numero uno last but not least number one
is the new camera I don't know if you
saw the camera on the Galaxy Nexus or on
the video I did four TLD today where I
explain this all the new features of ICS
the new camera is pretty badass you have
the ability to take instant photos
instant shutter is what they call it
zero shutter lag we can tap tap tap tap
tap to take photos and they're taking
the pictures you don't have any sort of
shutter lag no animations to slow you
down it's really fast you also have a
built-in panorama mode so if you have a
really wide landscape you want to take a
shot of you start panorama mode swing it
across and when you're done hit stop and
it'll stitch it all together and you got
yourself a really wide panorama shot you
can go 360 if you want and it has
built-in 1080p video recording finally
so every phone with ICS and a capable
sensor will have 1080p shots and built
into the gallery is a photo and / image
editor where you can edit your photos
add some sort of color effects or some
fisheye effects or whatever you want to
add to make your photos look cooler
before you share them on Google+ now I
got to give an honorable mention to
hardware acceleration in Android it
didn't make the top 5 but I'm really
looking forward to that just bringing
the entire experience together as a
seamless very smooth sort of interaction
brings to the whole professional appeal
so that's the side mention
awesome sexy yes so what are you looking
forward to an ice-cream sandwich if
you're even looking forward to it at all
I know some of you guys are looking at
me like well I use an iPhone so you know
I'm not looking forward to and that's
that's fine but if you are looking for
heard Ice Cream Sandwich what kind of
features are you looking forward to
something I didn't mention maybe cuz I
just want to get hyped up for this I'm
definitely gonna be reviewing the device
and I will be picking it up on day one
at the Verizon store two blocks that way
so let me know what you guys looking
forward to in the comments below and if
you did enjoy give it a thumbs up and
I'll see you guys in the next video
thanks for watching these
you